let's say 2022 is going to be the year
when i start to discover
the languages of india hi there steve
kaufman here and today i'm going to talk
about new year's resolutions new year's
goals remember if you enjoy my videos
where i talk about language learning
please subscribe if you listen to me on
a podcast service please leave a review
so
2022 it's a new year
typically
a new year is a time for us to assess
what we have been doing and what we
might do differently in the coming year
um
so i'm going to divide the the sort of
language or my goals or my resolutions
in two videos one that i'll do today and
then the next one that i'll do in a few
days
today i'm going to talk about language
goals which languages which languages am
i going to focus on what are my plans
um and then the next time i'll talk
about language learning activities and
how i plan to change some of my language
learning activities in the new year
first of all
i am by nature an optimist and i think
2022 is going to be a good year
uh i think
in many countries of the world we've
learned to live under very difficult
circumstances we've learned
the extent to which we have to
help each other
we need solidarity within
countries within our cities within
wherever we live and internationally we
have to work together and i think there
will be a renewed feeling that all the
minor things that cause us grief and you
know conflict are are minor and that the
most important thing thing for us to
think about is how can we all cooperate
better
and i think people are going to realize
that and i think there's going to be
this great sense of joy as we go back to
living our lives normally because i
think there will be a number of changes
i think there will be more medicines
available to reduce the burden on the
hospital system if we all get end up
getting a cold but we don't end up
you know in the intensive care unit of
hospitals then you know this is just a
condition that we're going to be able to
live with and lead our lives normally
hopefully with a renewed sense of how
important it is that we all support each
other that's my hope at least and i'm an
optimist now insofar as languages are
concerned
you may know that i have been
concentrating on arabic and persian i
originally set out to learn three middle
eastern languages
turkish persian and arabic
i then discovered how difficult it is to
get used to the sort of arabic writing
system so i said i'll just focus on the
two languages that use the arabic
writing system namely persian and arabic
and i'll put turkish on the back burner
turkish is a different language system
from i mean farsi is an indo-european
language arabic is a semitic language
turkish is again a different language
system but it is written in the latin
alphabet and that makes it a lot easier
especially for someone like me who likes
reading and listening as the main sort
of activity for learning languages
so it's been arabic and
persian
along the way i'd
come up you know i came up against the
problem with arabic that there is
standard arabic there's egyptian arabic
there's levantine arabic not to mention
you know the gulf arabic and and
sort of north african arabic
and so i ended up sort of saying you
know i'm going to focus on standard
arabic and i'm going to continue doing
that because so much of political
discussion and history books and
whatever is written down and
people on television and so forth speak
standard arabic so i want to be able to
access that so i need my standard arabic
but i have
put more and more effort into
certainly egyptian arabic
uh i've had a couple of tutors from
egypt
we have more and more content in
egyptian arabic and i've been listening
to these we have the many stories in
egyptian arabic
and of course part of the motivation is
that there's so many movies in egypt
that if i want to understand them i have
to learn egyptian arabic
but i've also increased recently
my attention to levantine arabic
again because first of all there are
movies from lebanon maybe predominantly
from lebanon
i found a wonderful
television station in jordan called
donia yadonya which puts out lots of
short
videos on youtube about everything from
you know women losing weight to healthy
issues to you name it all great stuff
for learning and as i get into
the different forms of arabic i'm more
and more convinced that arabic is just
one it's one language
i'm very glad that i started with
standard arabic
and that gives me a base from which i
can you know branch into
uh other forms of arabic and the goal is
to understand
so i don't have a tremendous amount of
opportunity to use the language
uh and you know if i were in egypt or if
i were in lebanon or or you know jordan
then i would probably try to speak more
the way they do but in a way it doesn't
matter there's a fair amount of
flexibility
and you can mix in you know
standard arabic egyptian arabic from
what i can gather levantine arabic
somehow the arab speakers all manage to
understand each other
and they use some kind of a mixture of
different forms of arabic and they and
they they communicate so i feel i can do
i can learn to do the same but i want to
be able to understand the different
forms of arabic so
first of all with regards to arabic i
will continue my activities
i'm going to increasingly use you know
short segments of tv programs that i can
find in youtube
uh what i tend to do is
uh try to get a hold of the mp3 file uh
in order to transcribe it so that i can
bring that into link and pick up the
words and phrases the automatic
transcription sometimes converts the
sort of levantine or egyptian words into
standard arabic but that's okay i hear
what they're saying and then i see the
equivalent in standard arabic but in
some cases it actually does transcribe
the sort of regional word
uh you know that that is in the actual
audio itself so that's working fine and
i'm enjoying it so there's where i am
with my arabic
i may start speaking a little more often
but i don't have that much time to speak
to my tutor um so that's a arabic
persian
i'll just continue i'm enjoying what i'm
doing i'm learning about persian food
persian culture persian history and i'll
just continue doing that
but i think the big thing that i wanted
to announce
is that i am going to start into some
other languages
and the reason is that
now that link 5.0 is it's available on
in ios it will soon be available on the
web version the web browser version and
in android
and we did promise that once we have
link 5.0 done that we will be adding
languages
for which we have 60 mini stories done
by volunteers now it's not going to
happen right away because obviously
although we've had
qa people testing link 5.0 once we open
it up to everybody
we will find bugs our users will find
bugs and so we'll be spending some time
before we get the five link
link 5.0 to sort of settle down but once
we do we'll be adding these languages so
i first of all i'll tell you which
languages
are available to upload once we get
around to doing it we won't do them all
at once and then i'll tell you which
ones i'm going to try and why all right
so
first of all these are the languages for
which 60 mini stories have been done
khmer
which i may not go wait we'll see
punjabi welsh
armenian icelandic jordan lithuanian
georgian rather lithuanian and tagalog
all of those have 60 many stories done
now for luxembourgish we have 45 stories
done for vietnamese we have 25 for
swahili we have 20 for thai we have 20
for urdu we have 20 and for latvian we
have 10.
so obviously until those other
languages until we get up to 60 mini
stories we won't be contemplating adding
them to link
if we are able to find volunteers
for these other languages to bring it up
to 60 then we will add them and if we
have volunteers for other languages and
we can bring it up to 60 we'll also add
them now of the list where we have 60
many stories done here are the ones that
i'm interested in i'm interested in
punjabi
because
just as it's so enjoyable here in
vancouver
uh checking out of a grocery store or uh
whatever store uh to speak uh persian
and my my doctor is from iran my barber
is from iran like there's iranians
everywhere so i have a lot of
opportunity to use persian
well we also have a lot of people from
the punjab
uh primarily sikhs living here in
vancouver
and i think would be a lot of fun to
surprise some of those people by
speaking to them in punjabi
now i may not go into great depth here
like with persian and arabic i'm so
committed to getting sort of to a b2
level there
i don't want to abandon those so i think
if i do the mini stories in punjabi
and a few other things i'll get to the
point where i can at least
perhaps have a short conversation with
someone
uh give them the impression that i speak
the language when i don't
and that gives me a certain amount of uh
sense of achievement so that would be
for punjabi so khmer
welsh i don't think i'm gonna tackle uh
armenian icelandic georgian
i don't see an opportunity to use them
here on the other hand with georgian you
know my wife and i you know i bought
this
book
uh iranian cooking book but it had
kurdish food georgian food all kinds of
different food from that part of the
world
and it's not impossible in the future
that we might go to turkey and georgia
and iran
and if that were the case then i would
at least do the many stories in georgia
but that's not on my plan for in my plan
for the year 2022.
uh lithuanian as well i don't see myself
doing that i might you know poke around
but i won't commit much time to it
tagalog on the other hand is of interest
because we have a lot of people from the
philippines here and
you run in them at uh you know for
example the lab where i do my blood
tests or you see a lot of people in
different professions from the
philippines uh in fact we had some work
done
in our kitchen and our our contractor
was uh they were a couple from the
philippines and a lot of the i wouldn't
say a lot but some of the trades that
they brought in were also from the
philippines so there's an opportunity to
use tagalog so tagalog and punjabi would
be two languages where i'm quite
motivated to do the many stories so that
i can get to some kind of a basic
conversational level maybe
uh but the main focus oh and one other
thing if we ever get
urdu if we get the 20 story mini stories
up to 60 then i would also do urdu and
we already have gujarati
and we also have a lot of ismailis in
canada so
i might just
once i do the punjabi which would be the
initial motivation then i might just
poke around the gujarati
because i do come across i know i have
some friends who is mainly and just to
throw some things at them in gujarati i
don't know what level of difficulty is
involved
i don't know how they're different i
don't know how different the writing
systems are
but let's say 2022 is going to be the
year when i start to discover
the languages of india
and if we end up eventually with hindi i
may also do something in hindi just as
in arabic i'm exploring you know
levantine arabic egyptian arabic as well
as standard arabic
then who knows where my exploration of
the
languages of the indian subcontinent
will take me but that's going to be a
major
focus of 2022
along with uh just dabbling in in
tagalog so that you know i can surprise
some of the uh
recent immigrants from the philippines
that i might come across here in
vancouver
so those are my sort of language goals
sort of stick with arabic
get to a better level of comprehension
in in
standard arabic egyptian arabic and
levantine arabic continue with my
persian
and and one thing about goals is i don't
want to feel that i'm obligated to do
anything uh pressure is bad i mean if
you if you want to make sure you can't
remember something just put pressure on
yourself to remember it pressure is bad
so it's an open-ended goal
just i want to improve i want to
continue enjoying these languages and i
want to improve if i discover that
punjabi is too difficult or tagalog was
too difficult then i will have no
hesitation in abandoning those things
there's no pressure on me
i think i i
previously said i wanted to get to a
level in in arabic where i can
understand podcasts and al jazeera i'm
still not there okay and i got you know
diverted by the way i do want to get
back to turkish so
no firm commitments and turkish is still
out there
uh particularly if at some point my wife
and i plan to travel to that part of the
world
but more immediately as i say punjabi
explore punjabi explore tagalog and
continue working on improving my arabic
in persian those are my language goals
the next video i do
will be about some of the different
approaches i'm going to take to my
language learning activities
and i'll leave you with a couple of
videos where i talk about
how to get ourselves going in language
learning thank you for listening bye for
now